the crisis surrounding Russia's invasion
of Ukraine suddenly seems even more
frightening than before and people have
begun to think the unthinkable this as
Russian President Vladimir Putin
threatened to the world of large
suggesting perhaps that he could be
ready to use nuclear weapons
it's a move that has triggered
widespread fears unparalleled since the
Cold War so the question we're asking
here on to the point is Putin's threat
is Russia ready to use the nuclear
option
foreign
[Music]
to discuss that question I'm joined by
Terry Schultz she is security and
defense specialist with deutschevela in
Brussels welcome to you also with us is
another DW colleague Vladimir jessipov
from our Russia desk who joins us from
London and a warm welcome to to Malta
Leeming who's with me here in the studio
he's with the Berlin Daily Newspaper the
target Spiegel and Martin let me begin
with you and Vladimir Putin's
announcement that he is putting nuclear
forces on high alert the debate must be
that he is willing to use the nuclear
option is that how it seems to you
not really I mean it's always hard to
tell what is what is in the mind in the
head of Vladimir Putin but but if he's
really willing to do it or if he's more
aiming at the nerve costume of the West
trying to spread fear and try to
disunify the astonishingly unified
Western Bloc I think this is more or
less what he's aiming at uh he did the
same in in 2014 uh it I think it's the
second grade of a Fourth Grade alert
system so it's not the highest alert but
but on alert and he's reminding us and
by us I mean the West that we're dealing
with a country not like Afghanistan or
Iraq but a nuclear power and that's what
we do okay uh Terry Terry Schultz in
Brussels Vladimir Putin has already used
similar language in recent days do you
see that from where you are as a threat
to our well-being in the immediate
future
well certainly Peter what NATO says is
simply that no one knows what's in
Vladimir Putin's mind and so they have
to be ready for everything and this is
what NATO was created to do to alert uh
every defense that it has possible among
its 30 allies just in case and I think
that they've been very reluctant to make
predictions about about what Vladimir
Putin will do what they say is they have
to be ready for everything he can do and
now of course we've seen what he can do
on the ground in Ukraine Vladimir what's
your take on what's going on inside
Vladimir Putin's head at this point in
time it's still the guessing game that
we've been involved in for days now
what we know now it's things which were
unimaginable for us like two two weeks
ago or one week ago I became becoming
reality on a very fast speed so I would
not surprise if Russia will go on for a
nuclear option especially as Europe
saying the shutdown of three for taking
out Russian Banks of Swift is a nuclear
option in terms of sanctions so Russia
just sending friendly friendly reminder
to Europe under the whole world the
trust has a nuclear option as well so I
would not surprised
to what extent Vladimir do you think
that the Russian lead of Vladimir Putin
is is now acutely isolated and has a
growing sense of the of his own
isolation
she seems to be quite isolated
um in the result TV appearances but
the question is his informational
isolation how much information from
outside to the outside world he is
getting through this Inner Circle so but
once again I'm I'm I have an impression
that it's all out war from the Russian
side against the West against the NATO
against the United States and the
European Union and um the escalation is
very fast in the Russians Russian side
is was always very very pretty in this
kind of response did for that like if
the Western imposed the sanctions on
Russia Russia entering the same time the
kind of tensions towards the West so the
stakes are very high right now and once
again Swift are the nuclear options
provoked this kind of response from the
Russian side in my opinion okay let's
say Let's uh let's have a close listen
to what exactly the Russian leader of
Vladimir Putin had to say what we've
been talking about here and then we'll
go back to Terry in brothels to get a
further assessment on where this
statement leaves us
not only are Western countries taking
unfriendly economic steps against our
country
I mean the illegal sanctions that
everyone knows about very well
but the top officials of leading NATO
countries are also making aggressive
statements about our country
therefore I order the minister of
defense and the chief of the general
staff
to put the deterrent forces of the
Russian military
to a special mode of combat Duty
beautiful Steel
[Music]
it's a very interesting phrase a special
mode of combat Duty just explain to us a
little bit about what Malta has already
referred to as the technicalities behind
this process this four stage process
that we have
I don't think anyone knows exactly what
Vladimir Putin means by this because we
are in Uncharted Territory as you've
said but again what NATO has to do and
what its nuclear armed allies have to do
is be ready for anything now it's quite
interesting that at this moment as we
are here on the show there has not been
a special meeting called as far as I'm
told and I have checked with my sources
to discuss specifically this nuclear
talk from from the Kremlin but at the
same time everything is always on high
alert at NATO certainly in in recent
weeks and days and so they have this
nuclear Planning Group that is always
kept abreast of of all of the threats
throughout the world and looks at what
NATO would do as a nuclear-armed
alliance with this as its you know last
stop option for defending the alliance
and everyone inside NATO knows what it
would do in in case of of a nuclear
attack okay I don't know exactly what
that would be okay let's move away from
the nuclear option to more conventional
Warfare there is a sense and I'm getting
it from lots of different sources the
the the the Vladimir Putin has perhaps
overreached himself in the operation so
far that they're not going as well as
well as he might have expected and that
obviously has a knock-on effect what are
you hearing where uh where you are at
NATO headquarters about that
we have had Intel briefings uh on on the
side uh from Western intelligence
officials and the first night was quite
dire in the first 24 hours we were told
that Kiev could fall within a day that
Russia was controlling the airspace had
taken over key airports and airfields
but by the second day that had
completely changed and the ukrainians
were fighting back better than anyone
had expected and and you know everyone
was was praising The Bravery of of the
Ukrainian not just Armed Forces but
civilians in fighting back and so
everyone thought maybe this won't be so
easy President Putin will not be able to
just walk in and take Ukraine and then
you've seen this outflow of further
weapons and contributions from from
Allied states to Ukraine more lethal
weapons look at this sea change in the
German position that makes a massive
difference not only will Germany be
sending weapons directly it will allow
other countries that are holding
german-made weapons to also ship them to
Ukraine and this is some something that
Germany had been holding up so this this
crisis in Ukraine has really shifted the
minds of any reluctant allies to help
Ukraine okay again there will be no
western boots on the ground but
everything they can do to help Ukraine
fight for itself they're doing Vladimir
at the same time there's no signs of
Russia backtracking on this offensive
measures on the ground in the Ukraine so
we don't know how the Russians will
react it's true that this offensive it's
not that Greek and it's not as
successful it's probably a Russian for a
Russian Ministry of defense or Russian
army and general staff was planning but
at the same time there's no science of
Russia
going back or stopping the sources so
the often thief on the ground is
continuing there's more Russian troops
entering the Ukraine as far as I see
from the Russian sources and there's no
signs of any any CIS virus virus okay so
let's see what melter has to say is is
Vladimir Putin making Headway in the way
he would hope or not
it very much depends on where now it's
the first banking day in in Moscow in in
Russia today uh because I think many
Russians start right now to feel that
their country is at War uh if they watch
the state television and and hear the
state news and so on and so on they were
just I mean not on the same information
level as we are in the west so it very
much depends on how the how the public
uh in Russia will react to for example
not being able to go to the bank and
just take the money out and and to
oligaries who are losing money and so on
and so on so the reaction of the
sanctions that were that were imposed on
Russia uh is feeling them right now your
newspaper today Malta had to add some
very interesting lines on this about the
credibility of uh of Vladimir Putin in
the eyes of of ordinary Russians if you
so will I mean you had you carried lines
like who believes in Vladimir Putin
Putin support come humbling or
yeah support crumbling I think is is a
devastating line for Vladimir Putin for
the estimation of his credibility I
can't predict how the how the how the
public in Russia is reacting to the news
of war that they are really at War the
sons are at War and are dying in Ukraine
which is supposedly a brothers and
sisters uh whom they are fighting too so
I can't predict what is happening
um but I would say just to just to see
any kind of diplomacy uh uh coined to uh
not talking to Vladimir Putin might be a
mistake we still have to find a way even
though we hate him even though we are
disgusted and even though all these
things that I really feel about uh you
have to deal with him it might be just
to wait until he is toppled might
prolong this war for weeks and months to
come and Vladimir when we talk about
these kind of setbacks there's also been
setbacks that the Putin has had the the
security Council or the backing from the
Chinese that he might have anticipated
would be much more positive he's not
getting that either so that is a that is
a diplomatic setback too
yes but if you look back for the 22
years of Vladimir Putin being in power
in Russia his current political career
began with the war in chichina mq it was
a very brutal warrant very disease for
international Russian forces are very
very brutal and suppressing this
Uprising or indigenous then we had this
Aleppo and Syrian operation of the
Russian troopage is quite very brutal as
well or it was very brutal as well and
now we have Russian tanks approaching
Kiev in in a large numbers in the
Russian David's defense Ministry it
communicated to tomorrow today sorry in
the morning to the citizens of Kiev to
leave this city basically which could be
assigned it could be assigned of the
Russian big scale military operation on
the city of Kiev
so I I would not expect much room to
negotiate with Vladimir Putin and I
don't see any any room for diplomacy
left it's like it's War
and Terry how is how is NATO likely to
uh to respond to that kind of talk that
we've now got the these large numbers of
Tanks moving perhaps towards Kiev and a
really serious threat of an aggravation
of the tensions and the conflict
just to return to the issue of diplomacy
I asked Secretary General stoltenberg
directly would you still talk to
Vladimir Putin after this Invasion and
he did not say that he was revoking his
invitation to talk to the Russians
anytime I think that
um they're going to leave open the
option
um the only reasonable option for ending
the conflict of dialogue and you'll also
note that the European Union in the
sanctions it placed directly on
President Putin and on foreign minister
lavrov it did not impose a travel ban on
them because they want them to be able
to come and talk they want people to be
able to go and talk to them nobody
thinks that there's a military solution
to this crisis and that's still the
predominant line but I think you have
NATO allies meeting now constantly in um
in at 30 all 30 allies around the table
talking about what more they can do to
help Ukraine short of course of boots on
the ground but you see more equipment
pouring in you see more Aid you see
humanitarian Aid Poland has offered to
be a hub for both NATO and the European
Union because you can no longer fly
supplies in so Poland has really stepped
up and taken the lead in transporting
this this equipment these additional
supplies of all kinds across the border
uh because that's the only way people
see the able to get a supplementary
materials to the ukrainians at this
point okay very much touch and go yes
and maybe it should be added and maybe
you agree or not Terry and Vladimir uh I
I think uh Vladimir Putin is not
interested to talk to the EU or to Nato
what counts for him is Joe Biden the US
president he's he's looking for a summit
that gives the whole world the
impression he goes eye and eye and and
equal to to the American president and
so this could be the last thing that
could be offered to him not now not
today not tomorrow but maybe in the next
two weeks or to come
what role are the Americans playing at
this point in time Terry it's a little
bit unclear to us from the from the the
perspective of the European theater
I think um I personally was watching
yesterday after this renewed talk of of
nuclear options to see if if you would
see President Biden come out and make it
make it some kind of address and and he
didn't
um and so I think that the I mean back
in Washington they're very much watching
every step and trying to calculate where
they can best use their weight I mean
remember this entire campaign this build
up the Americans surprised everyone with
how transparent they were and what their
intelligence not just to NATO allies in
closed session but openly speaking from
the White House Podium about what they
saw on the ground what they expected
President Putin might do and when and
they got a lot of skepticism about that
in fact they may not have had the dates
exactly right but what they warned about
did come to pass and when you talk to
people at NATO behind the scenes they
are very appreciative I mean there was
some skepticism uh about about U.S
intelligence and this strategy of sort
of telling everything that you know but
in the end allies have been appreciate
initiative that they didn't feel like
the Americans were going this alone and
I think that's why you don't see a lot
of unilateral American actions right now
but surely the people with all the
Intelligence on the ground and they and
they're watching this minute by minute
they're making a plan we just don't know
what it is yet interesting yeah if
they're making a plan but we don't know
what it is let's shift the focus from
that uh come back to Germany and talk
about remarkable scenes yesterday in
over the last 24 hours in the in the
German Parliament and on the streets of
the German Capital Malta it was one of
the most simple Laden days I I I can
think about for the last years I mean I
attended this uh this demonstration
between the Bron Brigade and and the
column of Victory it was huge it was
more than that 100 000 people and they
paraded uh towards the the Soviet Army
uh Memorial yeah in the in the middle in
the heart of Berlin with a red huge
complex with two tanks that that that
arrived in Berlin on on May 8th on May
7th I don't know
um and and the youth Red Army soldiers
standing above this waving Ukrainian
flags and this is this was a sign of
symbolism that we have the bundlestock
session yeah when three things happened
that were Unthinkable before I mean the
Swift sanctions
the uh a hundred billion Euro spending
for defense and and promising for
spending like the more than two percent
of the GDP in future for defense and uh
I forgot that and and the weapons weapon
delivery which was a taboo in German
politics for the last centuries okay
let's just listen to I mean the German
leader the Olaf Schultz that we're
referring to here has in some quarters
have been accused of not appearing to be
fully engaged in facing up to the
challenge posed by Vladimir Putin now
surely given what Malta has been saying
and what we're about to hear that can no
longer quite apply let's listen to Olaf
Schultz in his own words
Putin wants to create a Russian Empire
he wants to reconfigure Europe according
to his own ideas and he does not
hesitate to use military violence
we see this today in Ukraine so we must
ask ourselves what capabilities Putin's
Russia has and what capabilities do we
need to meet this threat today and in
the future
we must invest more in the security of
our country to defend our freedom and
democracy
from now on year for year more than two
percent of our GDP will be invested in
defense
foreign
[Music]
period Germany has essentially been a a
pacifist country there's been a very
strong streak of of pacifism in German
politics that has now apparently all
changed virtually overnight yes and and
it's done by a coalition of social
Democrats and green party uh which are
one of the most pacifist oriented uh
parties in Germany
um so it might be the end of German
pacifism I'm not quite sure about that
because pacifism means that you are
unwilling to fight
uh Germany doesn't fight so we are still
the spectators and and seeing this war
and uh try to influence it with the
Swift decision and things like that but
uh but would Germans be willing to fight
for that I have many doubts about that
Terry
Germany and Germans have have there's
been a revolution in how they perceive
their own Armed Forces this is a very
remarkable event and what does it mean
now for Germany and Europe in the
Ukraine crisis in the Ukraine conflict
yesterday when that speech was on I
could do nothing but just sit and listen
and wait for the Nuggets to drop about
how that would affect NATO Germany and
NATO you know what what you call a
pacifist country is often referred to as
a free rider here at here in Brussels at
NATO because Germany of course benefits
from the security of the alliance but
many people see it Sia does not having
contributed everything it could and that
did all change with this speech I spoke
with um someone working in in the
defense establishment in Berlin who said
that you know up until now without this
procurement decision announced yesterday
we would be able to to know that we
could buy sort of one quarter of an
airplane we didn't know if we would get
the funding after that to buy the rest
of the plane I mean these things that
don't sound that important perhaps to
the public ears are really important for
German defense I mean the spending above
two percent of GDP uh as NATO has
requested of all allies that's massive
that of course has been something
Germany was abs absolutely lambasted for
during the Trump Administration but also
in softer Ways by other administrations
this is truly a sea change in Germany's
role in NATO and I think it's going to
be welcomed very much by everyone there
at NATO headquarters including the
Germans themselves who are no longer
going to be under the spotlight for
financial reasons
what do you have to say about this
dramatic development that's being called
a a turning of the tide here in Germany
well the word dialogue was a mantra of
German foreign politics for many weeks
before the Russian invasion it was like
repeatedly mentioned in the bundestag
session dialogue dialogue dialogue with
Russia and now we see what's happening
on the ground and all this
right measures announced yesterday in
the German parliaments are long-term
measures financing the military spending
and delivering weapons to the Ukraine
but we need to look on the ground what's
happening right now in Kiev around the
cave and indication so what you're
saying is Vladimir Putin is not
necessarily going to be very impressed
by this development at this point in
time once again Russia sees itself since
eighth year it war with the West since
2014 and since the maidan revolution in
Ukraine the whole rhetoric of the
Russian government the whole rhetoric of
the Russian state made it was a war
rhetoric for
eight years right now so it's not
nothing could impress them and once
again again they have very clear
military goals on the ground
in Kiev especially and there as far as
we see right now they're going to
achieve their goals
what do you think
Terry you're you're so you I can see
your ambivalence about that statement
yeah just fill me in on exactly what you
know what what you're what you're
thinking there
no I think I think it's true this isn't
going to affect anything perhaps so
immediately on the ground
um although certainly it will be
welcomed that now Germany will both
directly send weapons to help Ukraine
and allow other countries to do so I
mean that can make an immediate
difference
um it doesn't speak to whether Ukraine
has a possibility to actually win this
militarily but you know President Putin
had quite a bit of success in Germany in
dividing public opinion about about what
the country should do I mean let's not
even get into Gerhart Schroeder's role
there but um you know that there there
is a division of opinion but what Olaf
Schultz did yesterday was say as a
country we are devoting ourselves to
Nato we are devoting a lot more money to
Nato by far the largest economy in
Europe if Germany spends two percent of
its GDP on defense on its own military
that is a massive increase in in
capabilities available to Nato once
again is it just another example of how
if Putin wanted weaker NATO if Putin
wanted a NATO that pulled away from his
borders remember that Germany is their
leading an enhanced forward presence in
Lithuania he has achieved now with even
more money behind it a much stronger
NATO we're running out of time quick
comments
yeah at the same time Ukraine is not a
member of the NATO so they're putting
money to the NATO is not especially
saving Ukraine so you can from NATO with
the money into the weapons but it will
not save the Ukraine interesting yes but
but but the German reaction to this
which was demonstrated yesterday in the
bonus talk I mean make it almost
impossible to spread this Unity between
the European Union and and in between
NATO because Germany was always
considered to be a weak link I mean uh
Putin has a special link to Germany he
was not educated but he worked in
Dresden as a KGB officer and so on he
speaks German so you always always tried
to pull away Germany from the rest of
Europe and it's not just Germany it's
the Hungary for example as well Auburn
was a close I would say almost trend of
Putin and he was joining the Swift
sanction as well okay I'm afraid that's
what we're going to have to leave it
thank you very very much for sharing
your thoughts with me I hope we've given
our viewers plenty of food for thought
about the uh the latest developments in
the crisis in Ukraine thanks very much
for joining us for now bye bye and
cheers
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]